d backs and the padres the first of two
and your ram truck starting pitcher for
the diamondbacks is the right-hander
merrill kelly four starts after that
thoracic outlet surgery
aston looking for some consistency here
bud
christian on deck here's the 2-2 to
tatis
harold kelly good start
[Applause]
there's a liner into right center field
over to play it is heath and grisham is
thinking too throw is going there and he
is going to get to
i was thinking two out of the box
[Applause]
first pitch swinging high to center nick
heath is out there and he won't have to
die for that one
number two
3-1 is tapped up the line
haven smith got a hustle here
and they just do beat hospital chris
paddock on the mound tonight for the
friars
using those high socks tonight you see
the four starts
in this arizona diamondback
check swing grounder to third and
machado in on the grass slings it across
in time to get smith
[Applause]
2-2
and a grounder right side shift in play
chronoworth will get it there in time
for out number two
heading into this brief two-game series
that is a good pitch fastball in 96
must've been looking for something else
on the two on will myers jake cronin
were thunder
fastball right there merrill gets his
second
oh
strikeout
pitch to him and that's strike three
call about merrell
uh back-to-back strikeouts looking there
in the second one two up two down i like
this mural kelly right here arson at
second he commented first here is nick
heath
sends one out to left center hangs up
there for profar and grisham will get it
carson kelly's coming in i'm at right
behind and nickith is in at third it's
two nothing diamondbacks
a little cross up in deep left center of
the padre outfield
and the jerks and profile had to move
out of the way he was camped underneath
the ball but grisham calls him off and
then clanks it thank you
two down heath the third and that is
strike three
myers backed up pretty deeply in right
ground ball the other way into the
backhand is tatis the throw one hopped
and picked by hosmer
so some tough throws have been coming
hosmer's way from tatis lately
and that one no different comes in on a
hop but osmo were able to pick it for
the out yeah it looked like he took his
time and then threw an absolute bullet
fourth inning here's a 2-2
and a swing and a miss struck him out
third strikeout for chris paddock two
down yeah perfect illustration of
changing eye levels that high fastball
[Applause]
on the ground and pick to the backhand
by hosmer his throw a little bit behind
paddock but panicking a good athletic
play reaching back to reel that in set
the table for the big boys up top
[Applause]
still holding double play ball here they
get one
giving the diamondbacks exactly what
they hoped for five scoreless they lead
it to nothing on the field and in
between innings in the dugout
swing and a miss and striking out his
heath fourth strikeout for paddock one
down here in the fifth inning
diamondbacks pitchers have now thrown 20
consecutive scoreless
innings so far five scoreless for
merrill kelly and now fernando tatis
junior leads off the san diego sixth
on the ground now that's a fair ball
right down the line over is calhoun
thinking two is tatis to throw to second
base will be late
a double to start things here in the
sixth inning for the padres and fernando
tatis junior and it's
90 feet away now with one down here in
the sixth inning
and a grounder to third throw is gonna
go to first for the out with a runal
score fernando tatis junior coming in
the padres are on the board it's two to
one
[Applause]
swinging a foul tip into the catcher's
mitt for strike three fifth strikeout
for paddock one down in the sixth inning
chance to tack on a run right here
there goes calhoun throw to third
he's in there
cool calhoun i think is a little gimpy
down there third base looked like he
grabbed at the back of his left leg as
he started to walk off the field he
grabbed him right there right after the
slide he was grabbing at the back of
that left leg perhaps hoping it was just
a cramp that would go away with time but
he's going to have to come out of the
ball game
here's a 3-2 and a line drive base at
left field the run is in and the
diamondbacks have their two-run lead
back 3-1 on a great job of getting there
by the freight train david peralta
dieback's answer back with a run here's
kelly now
fly ball left field
it's 5-1 carson kelly
that's six home runs in his last 10
games he is red-hot
one diamondbacks
[Applause]
caleb smith with a change up comes in
works a one two three seven
good pitch and he struck him out
first k for pierce johnson two down here
in the seventh that's good
i don't know if you came up with that on
your own that's good well i didn't come
up with the lower part but the jimmy
lower part yeah that's good yeah
three two pitches ball four see it jimmy
mike hazen put it over matching every
hitter he faced this spring
well that slider is an absolute weapon
[Applause]
cabrera getting over there
5-1 diamondbacks with one out in the
eighth
one on and a line drive to center
grisham makes the catch has a chance for
double play and he'll make it
almost overran that ball coming in had
to leap to make the catch
[Applause]
got him boom
fastball dotted it at 96.
fly ball right center
nick heath is there
josh robots done for the difference one
and two
right there ball game diamondbacks win
it 5-1
they keep rattling on they've won seven
of their last eight they get over 500.